بالنسبة للعديد من المسابقات ، تدور حول الاصطفاف
المباشر ضد أقرانك وجهاً لوجه ،
ولكن هنا في Battle Mountain Nevada ، تدور
المنافسة حول التغلب على كل
من يأتي قبل أن ترحب بك في
تحدي السرعة العالمي الذي يعمل بالطاقة البشرية
كل عام ، تأتي فرق الدراجات من جميع أنحاء
العالم إلى هنا في  السعي لكسر
جميع الأرقام القياسية للسرعة ، إنه سباق
مع الزمن أكثر من كونه سباقًا
ضد شخص آخر ، يأتي بعض هذه
الفرق إلى هنا يبحثون عن
السرعة القصوى التي يريدون كسر تلك السرعة البالغة
تسعة وثمانين نقطة وخمسة وتسعة
والمسار المثالي  من أجل تحطيم الأرقام
القياسية في State Road 305 في منطقة نائية
بوسط نيفادا ، هذا هو أفضل مكان
في العالم للقيام بذلك ، إنه أطول
طريق مستقيم وأكثر سلاسة
وجده أي شخص في العالم وهذا كل
ما في الأمر إنه أيضًا  على
ارتفاعات عالية مما يجعلها
أقل سمكًا ويمكن للدراجات أن تسير بشكل أسرع
ولكنها بعيدة كل البعد عن الدراجات العادية
المصنوعة من مواد خفيفة الوزن مثل
ألياف الكربون والكيفلار  هذه المركبات
هي أعجوبة في التصميم ،
إنها مزيج فريد من
الرياضة والهندسة ، وكلاهما ضروري
لأداء رياضي عظيم على دراجة عادية
لن يتخطى 45 ميلاً في الساعة في
هذه المسابقة بدلاً من ركوب
المتسابقين المستقيمين في وضع راقد أكثر ديناميكية هوائية
والدواسة
بأرجلهم أو أذرعهم مع أنظمة تروس خاصة
يمكن للركاب الوصول إلى سرعات تقترب من
90 ميلاً في الساعة أسرع بكثير
من معظمنا يقودها لأن الاحتياجات الحقيقية للذهاب
بسرعة كبيرة جدًا في ناقل الحركة ، لذا فإن
دورة واحدة من الدواسة هي 16 لفة من
العجلة في أعلى ترس لتقليل
راكبي السحب مغطاة بالكامل
بغطاء ديناميكي هوائي ، وبعضها ليس لديه
نافذة يمكن رؤيتها من الخارج ونستخدم
نظام الكاميرا هنا لأن عينيك في الواقع
هي رؤية داخل كبسولة
والطريقة التي تؤثر بها  حواسك
وأنه لا يمكنك الرؤية بشكل صحيح ، لا توجد
نافذة في الدراجة ، لذلك يمكننا فقط رؤية
المكان الذي نتجه إليه على شاشة
بحجم الهاتف المحمول المتصل
إلى كاميرا صغيرة في الجزء العلوي من الدراجات ،
يبدو الأمر وكأنك تلعب لعبة فيديو ،
فأنت منفصل نوعًا ما عن الواقع من
خلال شاشة الفيديو ، يصفها الكثير من الناس
بأنها مخيفة جدًا
ويمكنني فقط أن أتخيل أن الفرق لديها سبعة أيام
من المنافسة  لتحطيم الأرقام القياسية العالمية في
مجموعة متنوعة من الفئات المختلفة ،
هناك عدد غير قليل من النساء قادمًا هذا العام
لتحطيم الرقم القياسي العالمي
للسيدات ، كما أن الرقم القياسي لقوة الذراع نظرًا لأن
الدراجين مغلقين تمامًا ، فقد
ساعد أعضاء الفريق في إطلاق الدراجات من
خط البداية في اللحظة.  يأتي مباشرة
قبل إطلاق الغطاء ،
وفجأة أفقد العالم الخارجي نوعًا ما
لأنني لا أستطيع رؤية الشاشة
أمامنا إلا
[الموسيقى
] وعندما تكتب ليس لديك أي
إشارة إلى السرعة ، فليس
لديك أي مرجع لإدراك العمق
لذا فأنا أقود الركوب على طول كل ما
يمكنني رؤيته للأمام مباشرة ولا
أعرف مدى السرعة التي قطعتها والشعور
يختلف عن أي دراجة أخرى كنت على
راكبيها ولديهم ثمانية كيلومترات من الطريق
لبناء م  السرعة القصوى قبل
دخولهم في فخ سرعة 200 متر حيث
يتم قياس متوسط سرعتهم ، فأنت تر
د زيادة السرعة ببطء على طول ال
ريق حتى يتبقى لديك ميل واحد فقط وبعد ذل
تريد البدء في الركض بهذه ال
ريقة لا ترهق نفسك حتى  هذا
الشيء الذي يبدو وكأنه بيضة تسير
على طريق سريع في منتصف أي مكان
ولا يتطلب الأمر سوى القليل من الرياح
لتفجيرها قليلاً عن مسارها.
من
الإطار البسيط المثقوب إلى النفخ
على الطريق في مهب الريح ، أجرينا مكالمة وثيقة
مع Deere بالأمس ، فالجدول مرهق
بحيث يمكن للفشل أن يكون بشريًا ،
فنحن ننسى
شيئًا مهمًا جدًا حقًا يجب على جميع الكواكب أن
تتماشى مع ذلك.  ليكون رقمًا قياسيًا ، يجب أن يكون
كل شيء مثاليًا ، حيث
نجا الرقم القياسي للسرعة القصوى هذا العام ، لكن
الأرقام القياسية الأخرى سقطت ، حطم كين
تالبوت علامة عمرها سبع سنوات مسجلاً 50
1.5 8 أميال في الساعة في سباق كارين دا للرجال.
حطمت rk الرقم القياسي الخاص بها
في الركوب عند 46.5 4 أميال في الساعة في ذراع المرأة
، حطمت غريس والصغار في يوم العش
الهواة الرقم القياسي للدراجة ثلاثية العجلات
عند 60 نقطة 9 4 أميال في الساعة 3 أميال في
الساعة أسرع من العلامة السابقة التي
اعتقدت دائمًا في يوم من الأيام  سأكون
حامل الرقم القياسي العالمي ، وبعد ذلك
قال الجميع لا ، لن يحدث ذلك ، الحصول على
وظيفة حقيقية ، وظيفة حقيقية وأدركت أنك تعرف
ما سأفعله لأتمكن
من القول إنني عالم-  صاحب الرقم القياسي
في أسرع راكب دراجات ، إنه أمر
لا يصدق
[موسيقى]